The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good.
Well, why don't we go
ahead and get started.
We're going to be discussing
photovoltaic efficiency,
measurement, and
theoretical limits.
And there will be
plenty of natural breaks
over the course of
today's presentation
for us to have our debate.
This is a fun lecture
because we start out
by talking about how to measure
solar cell device efficiency.
Later, we will discuss
the theoretical efficiency
limits of solar cells.
Why do we focus an entire
lecture on efficiency?
Well first, as we
discussed previously,
efficiency is a very strong
determining factor for cost.
The rationale, again, is that
if you have low efficiency,
you're going to need
more commodity materials
to make a given watt peak.
That means you'll need a
larger area of solar module
to make a certain
amount of power,
which means you'll need
more glass, encapsulance,
and so forth.
So efficiency is a
strong lever determining
cost of all downstream
components except
for the area independent
factors like the inverter.
Secondly, efficiency is
tricky to measure accurately.
That is why there are only a few
laboratories around the world,
a handful, that are certified
to measure solar cell
efficiencies.
These are the
efficiencies that could
be reported in, say, the
efficiency compendiums,
an example of which
you've just picked up here
as one of the readings.
The reality is that we can
measure efficiency or get
a pretty close value for
an efficiency of a device
within our own laboratories.
But there are a number
of possible errors
that can creep up and nip us in
the heel if we're not careful.
And that's why we spend
some time in today's lecture
discussing those
potential pitfalls.
And thirdly, there
are new technologies
that are being
promised right and left
to overcome some of
the fundamental limits
of traditional solar cell
devices, like this one right
here.
And we have to understand
what those limits are so
that we can design better
ways to overcome them.
So learning objectives.
Bit of a small font here.
But the idea is--
our very first point
is to identify the sources of
record solar cell efficiencies
to understand where one
goes to look them up.
How do you find the record
efficiency of say, a silicon
device or a [INAUDIBLE] device?
Eventually, we'll
talk about measurement
of solar cell efficiencies.
And finally, the
theoretical or fundamental
limits to solar
cell efficiencies.
So the key concepts for--
learning objective number one,
to identify a source
for record efficiencies.
My go to place is a
Progress in Photovoltaics,
it's a journal and
in the PB field.
And every six
months, PiP comes out
with solar cell
efficiency tables
led by one of their editors,
Martin Green, professor
at University of New
South Wales in Australia.
The latest addition that I
could find was version 38.
I believe this was from
July or June this summer.
And every six months or so, they
come out with a new version.
And what you'll find
inside of that paper--
this is one of the four
handouts that you have today.
One of the three
articles that you have.
What you'll find inside of a
typical Martin Green solar cell
efficiency table is a
listing of-- in table one,
a listing of individual cells.
In table two of modules.
And within the cells,
any new record efficiency
will be shown in bold.
Over the six months preceding
the release of the latest
version, there were indeed
four record efficiencies
that had been made.
And that's pretty
impressive advance.
Note one thing which
we'll come back to later.
Note the plus minus
appearing here
after the efficiency number.
Is anybody surprised
at that number?
Ashley, did you expect
it to be that big?
AUDIENCE: No, not that big.
PROFESSOR: Not that big, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But say the record efficiency
of crystal silicon device, 25%
plus or minus 0.5.
Pretty large delta.
We'll explain some
of the reasons
why that error bar is so large.
Another thing to keep in mind.
Look at gallium arsenide
at 28.1%, just achieved
by Alta Devices in March.
Keep that number,
28.1 plus or minus
20% in your mind, at
least the first one, 28.1
We'll march on to the module
efficiency tables right here.
So now the gallium
arsenide module efficiency
record for the efficiency tables
right here is 21%, or 21.1%.
Crystalline silicon has dropped
from 25 to 23 and so forth.
And this is fairly typical
that record module efficiencies
are in the order of 2% to 7%
lower than record efficiency
cells.
Can anybody guess
why that might be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You have a mix of
different performers.
And when you connect them
in series and in parallel,
you're going to be limited by
the lowest voltage or current,
respectively.
Yes.
OK.
So certainly there
are mismatches
between the individual
devices inside of a module.
That's where the
majority of that
comes from for, say,
crystalline silicon
or discrete monolithic wafers.
But how about for some of
these thin film devices?
They are deposited using these
large chemical vapor deposition
reactors, for example,
or PVD reactors.
And you deposit a uniform
thin film over a large area,
use lasers to cut little
trenches in the films
and discretize the
devices that way.
So how come there
are differences
between record cell and
record module for thin film?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So if you have inhomogeneities
in thickness or in composition,
or even in surface
quality from region
to region in that
large area, you're
likely to reduce
your performance.
One analogy, since
I know many of you
are mechanical engineers,
one analogy to this
is when you're doing tensile
tests with ceramics or brittle
specimens at room temperature,
and you pull on your specimen,
and you obtain a certain
fracture stress, you then take
that smaller piece, pull again.
Now the fracture
stress is higher.
Pull on that smaller
piece that broke off.
Yet again, another fracture
stress is even higher.
In other words, in
that large specimen,
there was one point
that was extremely weak,
another point that
was sort of weak,
and another point
that was mildly weak.
And as you increase the
size of your specimen,
the likelihood of having one of
these failure points increases.
That's an analogy, let's say,
to a large area module, as well,
if we could have pinholes
or other manufacturing
defects inside of
a large area module
that could reduce the
performance locally,
and everything is
interconnected,
it tends to drop the
performance overall.
So we have the record
laboratory efficiencies.
This is another
reference source.
I am not personally aware
where Larry Kazmerski publishes
this on a regular basis.
I know he maintains this table.
And if you email
him very nicely,
he'll email you back with
the most updated version.
But I'm not aware of
any publication outlet
where this is
regularly appearing.
But nevertheless, it captures
the record efficiencies
versus time the same
way that you, too,
could do if you went to
the Martin Green records.
And I believe we're at,
was it, number 39 now?
38.
We're at Version 38.
And if you went back in time
to all of the different tables
and tabulated the
results versus time,
you would get a plot that
looked very similar to this
for each technology.
So next up we're going
to identify the sources
of standard solar spectrum.
So we know the
record efficiencies.
We're taking their
word for it right now
that they did everything right.
Now we're going to learn
what that everything is
and how to do it
right, or at least some
of the pieces of doing it right.
We're going to identify,
first of all, the sources
of standard solar spectrum.
So in one scenario
you could say, well,
let me just go outside and
measure the solar spectrum.
If you go outside today,
it's kind of cloudy.
The spectrum would look very
different than tomorrow.
And so it would
be very difficult
for you to compare the
performance of your device
against somebody who
might be in Germany
or somebody who
might be in Finland,
might be in Brazil.
So that's why we come up
with the standard reference
solar spectrum.
And it's shown right here.
The ASTM standard
reference spectrum
is shown on the nice NREL
website for air mass zero.
That's in the outer reaches of
our earth's atmosphere and air
mass 1.5, which is assumed
to be a standard in, say,
temperate climates.
So there have been numerous
revisions to the standard.
You might want to use
the latest one just
to make sure that everything
is up to proper spec.
The latest standard
here, essentially they,
in very pedantic
detail, walk through all
of the possible scattering
mechanisms in the atmosphere.
And this is their justification
for the specific solar spectrum
that they're measuring.
And so you have a nice
explanation in much detail.
Let me just show you once
again the standard spectrum.
You've seen this before.
You've worked with it
in homework number,
I believe it was one or two.
And we see AM0, AM1.5
direct, and AM1.5 global,
AM1.5 global being the capture
of sunlight from a full
hemisphere, direct being
looking very closely,
in a very small solid angle,
directly at the sun on a sunny
day.
Given these
atmospheric conditions
with a small amount of
atmospheric scattering,
obtaining an integrated power
density, watts per square meter
if you integrate over all
wavelengths, it's about 90%
of the global full
hemisphere measurement.
Any questions so far about this?
OK.
So that's pretty straightforward
and the measurement devices
for the global and
direct measurement today.
Obviously we didn't have
those fancy contraptions 60,
70 years ago in quite the same
way, with the same materials
and the same design and
the same quality of glass.
But we had other
measurement devices.
And you'll see in a few slides
how the solar constant has been
varying as a function of time.
Granted, the solar
output also varies,
but our ability to measure the
solar output varies as well.
So if you look at the evolution
of the solar constant versus
time, this is the
number of watts
per meter squared in the outer
reaches of our atmosphere,
so AM0.
And you can see that
our values have changed.
So if you were to
ask, is this because
of the change of our
measurement capabilities
or because of the change of the
solar output, the people who
study the sun will tell you that
the variation in solar output
is expected to be rather small.
So the likely origin of
this large fluctuation,
pre-1960, is most likely
due to our ability
to measure the
spectrum accurately.
So next we'll describe how to
simulate the solar spectrum
in the laboratory,
and we'll describe
how a solar simulator works.
So great.
We have an idealized
solar spectrum right here.
How do we recreate this in
a laboratory environment?
How do we obtain a
light source that
follows this profile exactly?
Well, barring the ability to
recreate a small fusion source
in the laboratory
and the ability
to introduce exactly
the right Fraunhofer
lines into our
spectrum, we are not
going to be able to
reproduce that exactly.
But we have several techniques
that come fairly close.
So the solar simulator.
This is a schematic coming
off of the Newport website.
Many of the solar simulators
in the laboratories
here at MIT, as you'll
see as you walk around,
be Newport Oriole
or related brands,
we have the light
source back here.
Note the type of
the lamp right here.
It's a xenon arc lamp.
Mirrors, essentially
a series of optics
to create the right
form factor of the light
and ultimately work our way
toward a planar incoming beam.
And the what's called spectral
correction filter, which
is right in the middle
of the optics train.
And that's
essentially to correct
for variances between the
emission of the xenon arc
clamp and the ASTM solar
spectrum as defined right here.
And we have a shutter, as
well, to block the light.
For example, if your
device or cell or material
is photosensitive, you
might want to not expose it
for long periods of time.
There's also-- when I say
photosensitive I don't mean
that the device will
stop working under light,
but that the
performance will change.
There are materials, for
example, amorphous silicon
that we discussed, where
the performance does change
as a function of illumination,
cumulative illumination
intensity.
So another interesting
thing to note here
is that we have
quasi-planar light coming
in at the end of
this optics train.
But if we're going to be
measuring, for example,
concentrating solar
cell apparatus,
it's much more important to have
a higher degree of planarity
of the incoming light, and then
other optics would be used.
One might envision,
for instance,
increasing the distance
between the light source
and the actual sample,
or the optical path
length between the collimating
mirror and the sample.
So now that we have light
approaching our sample right
here, so light is
incoming on the sample,
we have three things, broadly,
that we have to worry about.
We have to worry
about uniformity
of the light, the
uniformity from small region
to region of the
illuminated area.
We need to worry about
spectral fidelity.
That means, how closely does
the spectrum of our lamp
match the ASTM standard
solar spectrum?
And thirdly, temporal stability.
That means if I turn on
the lamp this morning
and want to take in a
measurement immediately,
is it stable yet?
OK.
Let me wait a half hour for
things to-- for example,
the thermal loads inside of
the system to reach equilibrium
with environment.
Now I'm going to measure it.
What if I come back
in an hour and a half?
Will I still get
the same result?
What if I come back
tomorrow or next month?
Temporal stability is
another major concern
for solar simulators.
On the right-hand side
is just an example
of the radiance versus
wavelength of a given light
source versus time.
And you can see there's a new
lamp after a certain working
period of 1,200 hours.
So we have non-ideal
matches, several examples
of light sources that
don't quite get it right
or have several spikes
in the output spectrum.
So in all cases, here
the AM1 direct spectrum
is shown in this dash dot line.
And different light
sources are shown
either solid or dashed lines.
So not great.
And then finally, we
reach our xenon arc lamp
with air mass filters.
And the filters are to
suppress certain peaks
and certain general
portions of the spectrum
so that we have an approximation
of our ASTM standard reference
spectrum.
And you notice that
it's not perfect.
You notice that there are spikes
in the output of the xenon arc
lamp, as you might expect
from the physics involved
in the light source.
This is of some
concern if your device
is particularly sensitive to
a region, a spectral region
where those might be present.
So it's not a bad idea
to take a measurement
of your light source
and actually understand
how it compares, how it
matches up against the ASTM
standard spectrum.
In terms of standards, or
ranking different types
of solar simulators,
there are three classes
according to the IEC standards.
There are, as well,
other common standards.
There's a standard
used in Japan,
and the ASTM standards as well.
But let's focus
on the IEC 904-9.
These are the requirements
for solar simulators measuring
crystalline silicon
single junction devices.
So it's a very
specific standard.
And in a few slides
we'll explain
what the potential
differences are
when you're measuring other
types of solar cell materials.
We have the spectral match,
or spectral fidelity.
We have the non-uniformity
and the temporal instability
in this case, since
we're defining
a relatively small parameter.
Class A solar simulators
have relatively tight specs.
But you'll still notice
here that the non-uniformity
of the irradiance plus or minus
2%, the temporal instability
plus or minus 2%.
This is where you start to
see some of those error bars
on the record efficiency
measurements, right?
So if a laboratory has a very
good handle on its reference
solar simulator, it will be
able to calculate these effects
and estimate what their impact
is on the actual solar cell
efficiency measure.
Note that the
temporal instability
for the Japanese standard
is a little bit more
stringent than the IEC test.
Minor detail, but depending
on who your collaborators are,
where they are in
the world, they
might be using a different
standard than you.
Just keep that in mind.
The solar simulator
downstairs in Building 35,
in the laboratory
that several of you
have seen yesterday when you
did the phosphorus diffusions--
I poked my head in and
saw everybody there.
So about a dozen
of you might have
walked past the solar
simulator in the laboratory.
That's a large area, as
in the illuminated area
at the working plane is around
20 by 20 centimeter squared.
And it is a Class
AAB solar simulator.
So I believe that would be
spectral match, non-uniformity,
and then temporal stability.
So you'll typically see
solar simulators rated
in this way, AAA, Triple A, or
Class B solar simulator, or AAB
and so forth.
So again, note the
significant figures.
That's where that comes from.
Pretty straightforward.
Next we're going to
describe how to accurately
measure and report
cell efficiency
and some common pitfalls to
avoid when actually measuring
the cells.
So this is really
directed toward people
who are doing active research
right now in the field of PV.
For those who aren't, enjoy.
And we'll come back as soon
as this little section is
over to the debate.
And finally some topics
of general interest.
So this is just a
small subset of things
to keep in mind when you're
measuring an actual solar cell.
This is by no means
a comprehensive list.
There are, indeed, people
who spend their entire lives
optimizing and perfecting the
art of measuring solar cells.
So the very first thing
that you might want to do
is have a reference solar cell
encapsulated, and then mailed
to you after a measurement is
performed at a certification
laboratory.
So this is an example of a
very small crystalline silicon
solar cell device inside
of an encapsulated frame.
And the encapsulation
is meant to prevent
any degradation
to the solar cell,
as well as damage that might
incur during accidental use.
And this cell is called
a reference cell.
It was tested at NREL.
The current voltage, the
short circuit current,
open circuit voltage, and
fill factor of that device
is well-known and reported,
and is essentially
sent with that device
back to our laboratory.
Now whenever we want to make
a new measurement on any cell
that we want to measure
inside the laboratory,
we'll measure the
reference cell first just
to make sure that our solar
simulator is well-behaved.
When I say well-behaved,
what could happen?
Well, one of the many
things that could happen
is that the lamp
intensity decreases.
That's probably the most
common thing that can happen.
You'll just have an
overall reduction
in the output of your
lamp, in which case
you'll notice a reduction
in what cell parameter?
Current, voltage,
or fill factor?
Current, right?
So the light
intensity decreases.
You'll have a
reduction primarily
in your current, logarithmic
reduction in voltage.
So you have your standard
calibrated reference cell.
This is definitely something
that each laboratory that
is going to be serious
about measuring efficiency
should have.
This is also an apparatus that
doesn't leave our laboratory
except for class purposes.
It's something we
treat very carefully,
since I think the cost
ran in the few hundreds
or thousands of dollars.
Avoid extraneous--
basically, avoid
light from coming
in from outside
of your solar simulator.
It is often shown, or
the solar simulators
are often shown in this manner
right here, where you have
everything out in the open.
That's to show you
what's going on inside.
When you actually
take the measurement,
typically you have a
small black curtain
that's light tight around your
apparatus, or maybe even a box.
Ensure 25 degrees C
measurement conditions.
Remember that the open
circuit voltage can change,
depending on the band gap.
The larger the band gap,
the smaller this effect.
The smaller the band gap,
the larger this effect.
The VOC can change as
the temperature changes.
And so it's important
to have a good handle
of your temperature.
That means that you might, for
instance, have active heating
and cooling on your chuck.
And you'll also, at the minimum,
be measuring the temperature
on top of the chuck, where the
actual solar cell will sit,
not far away removed through
some layers of insulation
away from the chuck.
Even if your temperature is
not precisely at 25 degrees
C, if you know the temperature
dependence of your solar cell,
you can correct for it or
account for it to pull it back
to 25 degrees C.
Next, choose your
probe locations
judiciously to avoid
series resistance losses.
Let's think that
through for a second.
So if we have our solar
cell device right here
and we're going to be
measuring its cell efficiency,
if I put one little probe
right here in the corner,
then the current that's
being generated over here
has to travel a very large
distance through a lot of metal
to reach that point.
But if I have probes that
essentially will consist
of many different
individual metal points,
and they come down on either
bus bar like shown right here--
where you see the green right
here, and off of the green are
many little probe tips,
individual probe tips that
will make contact
with the bus bar,
so you have essentially
one coming down right here,
another coming down right here--
your series resistance losses
will be much less.
But one thing to keep
in mind is that when
you do have these
probes sticking
on top of your
solar cell device,
they will scatter some
of the light as well.
So there are best practices
in terms of what color
they should be and how tall
they should be, as well.
So choosing the
probe location is
a large step toward
achieving high efficiencies.
I don't under
emphasize that point.
It really does make
a huge difference
where you put your probe
tips, especially for cells
with high series
resistance, which
can be several of the
new materials that
are being developed.
Account for spectral mismatch
between calibration cell
and your cell.
Let me drive that point home.
So I have a crystal and silicon
calibration cell right here.
I know its spectral response.
I know at what wavelengths
it responds the strongest.
And so it will detect any
mismatch between the ASTM
standard and the actual
light source there
where it responds most strongly.
Now let's imagine
that I'm designing
a new organic material
that responds really well.
Pick something, the infrared.
And so now silicon
will stop responding,
let's say, at around
1,100 nanometers.
So anything beyond here,
silicon won't be able to detect.
But let's say my device
is very sensitive
in that spectral region.
My silicon calibration
cell says go ahead,
take your measurement,
everything's fine.
It matches your ASTM standard.
But then when I stick my cell
in there, all of a sudden I'm
getting a super high efficiency.
I just made an organic
device, and my efficiency's
11%, which would
be a world record.
I'm ecstatic.
I'm really happy until I do
the quantum efficiency of both
the standard calibration
cell and my new cell,
and I realize, wait a second.
They're nowhere near
each other in terms
of their responsivity, what
region of the solar spectrum
they can respond well at.
And the reason I'm
bringing that up
is, again, to
emphasize we have, say,
for example, an amorphous
silicon device, a gallium
arsenide device over here,
a SiGs device showing
the different regions
of the solar spectrum,
the solar spectrum shown in this
dark orange in the background
right here, peaking
at around 550.
We can see that the
different materials
are responding to different
regions of the solar spectrum.
And crystalline
silicon would be in
between the amorphous
silicon-- actually,
it would be a
little further over,
be starting up at around between
1,200 and 1,100 nanometers.
So we can see how
different materials
are more sensitive to different
regions of the solar spectrum.
And there's even a
standard test method
for determining the
spectral mismatch
parameter between your device
and the reference cell, an ASTM
standard for it.
And the typical way
to account for this
is to measure the
spectral irradiance
as a function of wavelength
of your light source,
measure the quantum efficiency,
meaning the responsivity versus
wavelength of your device, and
then measure your calibration
cell.
And using that
math, you can really
begin to normalize for
these extraneous effects.
Why do I bring that up?
I bring that up
because there was
an example, several examples,
of folks in the literature--
I've taken off their
names, so protecting
the innocent here-- folks
in the literature who
report very high efficiency
devices, or at the time
was a near-record
efficiency device.
What they showed were the
QE curves of the devices,
and then the IV curves
of their devices.
And you guys, in your homeworks,
calculated the short circuit
current, which is shown here--
essentially the intercept
with the y-axis-- you
calculated the short circuit
current from the QE.
So you know how to
perform that calculation.
Well, guess what?
Folks at NREL also know
how to do that calculation,
and a whole lot more.
So the folks at NREL did that
and said, well, wait a second.
When I do the
integration of your QE,
I'm not getting these short
circuit currents over here.
I suspect what happened was,
in your solar simulator,
you were using a
silicon reference cell.
But your cells were more
sensitive to a different region
of the solar spectrum--
in this particular case
they were more sensitive to
the shorter wavelengths--
and you didn't have a properly
calibrated solar simulator.
So you're over reporting
your current outputs.
And of course that's very
embarrassing for a group.
In this particular case there
were merits on both sides.
There was a rebuttal
to the rebuttal.
So it's not a simple
black and white case
for this particular story,
although the logic does
fall more strongly on one side.
So this is to say, avoid
this sort of controversy.
Perform your
measurements properly,
don't over report
your efficiencies,
and when in doubt, you can
always ship your cells to NREL
or [INAUDIBLE] or another
certified testing center
and get a certified
cell efficiency.
Then you can place your IV curve
inside of your publication,
and in the little
corner over here
it'll have the figure
of NREL or [INAUDIBLE]
and the properly
certified information.
Now that can be
rather complicated
if you're, for example,
growing organic materials that
degrade quickly.
Somehow you have to
transport it over there
without it degrading.
And that's where arranging
in advance the transfer
of the materials, and
perhaps even looking
into what sort of
transfer chamber
you're going to encapsulate your
device in could be of interest.
But at the very least,
please, please, please
remember spectral
response mismatch
when you're doing
efficiency measurements.
Any questions so far?
AUDIENCE: So then does NREL
also make non-silicon reference
cells?
PROFESSOR: So NREL actually
doesn't make these cells.
They're local
companies that live
right around NREL that are
manufacturing these and putting
them together.
NREL will test those cells.
Since it takes a few
months, typically,
to get turnaround on a cell
efficiency measurement--
unless you're fast tracked
in because your device is
degrading or you've
arranged in advance
and kind of put your place
in line-- because it takes
a few months turnaround,
there's actually
a premium on inventory.
And so these companies will
manufacture the devices,
send them in, get them
tested and calibrated,
or get the calibrated
measurements performed at NREL,
and then bring them
back to the company
and put them on the shelf
until you put pick up the phone
and call them and say,
I'd like a certified cell.
You can actually
make your own, too,
if you follow a set
of standard protocols
that you can receive
from the folks at NREL.
I believe Keith Emery might be
a good point contact at first.
There are a very
specific set of protocols
that you should
follow if you want
to make your own in the lab.
In other words,
you have to design
the contacts a certain way,
the encapsule in a certain way,
make sure that the materials
comprising the remainder
are black so that they don't
reflect the light back in,
little details that are
only gathered by experience.
If you follow all
of those parameters,
and the folks over there,
Keith Emery or Paul [INAUDIBLE]
look at it, and they
inspect it and say,
yeah, yeah, looks good,
then you can get that tested
and serve as a
calibration cell as well.
So you can circumvent some
of the cost associated
with buying a certified
cell from a company.
But there is a premium to them.
They don't tend to be
particularly cheap.
So yeah, if you have
another material
and you'd like to
have it calibrated,
you can make your own
calibration reference standard
as long as it doesn't degrade.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Putting
the multiple contact
in yours while you're
measuring the efficiency.
Is that very representative
of the devices that
actually work in the field?
PROFESSOR: So there
are a lot of things--
let me spend a minute waxing
poetic about the discrepancies
between these cell
efficiency measurements
and what actual cells
experience in the field.
We understand the logic behind
cell efficiency measurements.
We understand we have to have
a universal way of comparing
a cell in Japan, in Boston,
in Freiburg, Germany.
So we understand that we
need some standard method
of cell measurement.
This cell measurement
proves very useful when
you measure the output
in terms of peak watts,
because then you can multiply
by the number of peak hours
of sunlight per day and estimate
the energy output as a function
of location on the earth.
So it has its uses.
Now as to its drawbacks.
We're measuring at
25 degrees Celsius.
These cells are typically
operating around 60.
We know that there's a voltage
drop, primarily a voltage drop
with increasing temperature.
That's point one.
Point number two, the
contacting scheme.
Typically on these
devices in a module,
you'll have soldered
contacts in the front,
and so they make contact
with the entire bus bar,
but really, depending on
your soldering machine,
only in a few locations
where there's really
a good electrical contact, and
on the back in three locations.
So yes, there are differences
in how the cell is
contacted in real life.
Could be one of the reasons for
discrepancies between module
and cell efficiency, probably
one of the minor ones compared
to homogeneities.
Why don't we take a
quick little pause
right here before we dive
into describing the efficiency
limitations of a typical
cell and get some cool demos
at the very end.
What we're going to do is
have ourselves a quick debate.
So I'd like to call forward
at the front of the room
the representatives of the
two teams, one of which
is going to debate in favor
of the development of novel
materials for solar cells.
Let me give you an example
of one material that's
attracted quite a bit of
attention, which is pyrite.
I can pass this around as folks
are coming up to the front.
Here's an example of an
iron sulfide-based mineral
which is purported to
have a very high degree
of manufacturability because of
the large resource abundance,
and also the large
refining capacity
for the respective
elemental constituents.
There is a gap between the
performance of current pyrite
cells and their theoretical
record efficiencies, quite
substantial, the
record efficiency being
up closer to 20%, the
actual efficiency being down
at around two.
That is not unlike, for
example, tin sulfide,
or other related materials.
I'd say copper zinc
tin sulfide is probably
the most advanced at around
10%, but still about half
of its theoretical limit.
And so the big question
that we're going to debate
is, does it make sense
to invest a lot of funds
to come up with these
earth abundant alternatives
for our existing
solar cell materials,
our cadtel, our copper
indium gallium selenide,
cognizant that
the supply of some
of these heavier elements,
tellurium and indium,
is limited.
And we may not have enough of
these elements in the earth's
crust to scale up to
the terawatts level.
And so we'll hear
two points of view,
one in favor of development of
new materials, and one against.
And just to situate ourselves
in a position or a location
where these debates
actually do happen,
you can imagine
yourself, for example,
in the Office of Science
and Technology Policy,
which reports directly
to Barack Obama.
These are about 50 PhDs
who are all in an office
under the direction
of a director,
thinking deeply about some
of the scientific challenges
that our nation faces and the
proper scientific response,
coordinating amongst many
agencies, including the DOD,
DOE, NSF, and so forth.
And so you can picture
yourselves in a debate,
in a lively discussion,
all friendly,
but really with the potential
to influence national policy.
Do we direct resource funds
to develop these novel, earth
abundant alternatives that we
might need in 10 years' time?
Or do we focus and allocate
resources elsewhere?
So I'll welcome the two
participants up to the front.
So folks want some
insight into where
the Office of Science
and Technology Policy
actually decided to go.
A gentleman who took a version
of this course in Berkeley
in 2003, I think it was,
his name is Cyrus Wadia.
Graduated with his
PhD from Berkeley
and actually went off to
join Office of Science
and Technology Policy.
He took his class project
for the PB course, which
was analyzing
alternative materials
and published that
paper that you
read by Cyrus Wadia
on resource abundance
that was published in 2009,
for that work earned himself
a TR 35 reward from Tech
Review, and then joined
the Obama administration's
OSTP, and has
been developing the Materials
Genome Project within OSTP.
The first solicitation
for proposals was issued,
I believe, a week
and a half ago.
So that's funneled
through the NSF.
But it's a larger
effort to develop
some of these materials
involving NSFD, DOD, DOE,
and so forth.
So it actually did come
to fruition through OSTP.
Budgeting is always the
big question, though,
because that, of
course, gets done
through the
committees in Congress
and ultimately reconciled
between the House
and the Senate, and has
to make it through OMB
and finally to the
individual directorates.
So that's how things
actually get done.
But it takes the vision
of OSTP, sometimes,
to drive these larger
projects forward.
So we'll wish him the best.
We're going to describe
the efficiency limitations
of a typical solar cell now.
And what I'll do is I'll pass
around some of these books
just to, again,
situate ourselves.
Did I grab Jenny
Nelson's on the way out?
Thought I did.
Hm.
OK.
Well.
Peter Wurfel and--
oh, there it is.
Yes, absolutely.
So there's two books
that are entitled
Physics of Solar Cells.
You can see it's a
very popular topic.
And one is The
Photovoltaic Handbook.
All refer to some aspect
of efficiency limits.
And as you look
through your sheets,
you'll see at the
bottom, typically
the different pages of each
of the books are listed here.
So the very first thing
that we should consider
before we get into
PV technology,
we just have some solar
device looking at the sun.
And the sun is radiating at it
at 6,000 Kelvin, 5,800 Kelvin.
And it, the solar contraption
on the surface the earth,
is radiating back at the sun
with black body radiation
at 300 Kelvin.
So much lower power from
Stefan Boltzmann's Law
we know exactly
the amount of power
being emitted by that device.
So the two are
radiating at each other,
and they're in equilibrium.
And that results
in the very first,
we'll call it
blackbody efficiency,
or maximum solar heat
engine efficiency,
which would be around 86%.
So that's our first
fundamental cutoff.
Now that 86% is averaged
over all wavelengths.
There tends to be a wavelength
dependence to this as well.
So the next step was
to say, OK, well,
we know that we
can't do better than
the theoretical
thermodynamic limit of one
object looking at another.
But what is the actual
limit of a solar cell?
And this was a question
that the first developers
of the solar cell
asked themselves.
So Prince was one of the
three of the team that
in 1954 published on the crystal
silicon solar cell device,
and very quickly followed
it up with another article
here in JP focused on the
theoretical efficiency limit.
And a curve was proposed,
looking much like this,
with two data points for
germanium and silicon,
theoretical limits, that
is, and power density.
So not a conversion efficiency
per se, but a power density.
And of course, assuming a
certain input power density,
one can calculate an
efficiency from there.
And along came--
well, at this time,
H-J Queisser had just moved
over from Germany to Palo Alto,
to The Apricot Barn, and
working with Shockley,
the esteemed
Shockley at the time,
to develop a detailed
balance model
for describing how a
solar cell performs,
or what its ultimate theoretical
efficiency limit could be.
Now what a detailed
balance model does
is just basically
accounting, accounting
for all of the photons coming
in and out of the device.
Through the photons,
the electron hole pairs
are generated.
This is assuming a very
high quality material
that does not have any
form of recombination other
than radiative recombination.
So we talked about the different
methods of limiting lifetime.
Radiative recombination
is one of the methods
of limiting performance
that occurs in high quality
materials.
If you have a poor
quality material,
you'll have non-radiative
recombination,
say, Shockley-Read-Hall
recombination.
But in the detailed
balance model,
only radiative
recombination was assumed.
That way you can count
number of photons coming in
and number of photons
going out of your device.
Furthermore, they assumed
that the mobility of carriers
was infinite inside
of their material.
A few laughs over here
coming from the folks who are
working on organic materials.
But it's true.
They assumed that the
mobility was infinite,
such that the separation
of the quasi Fermi
energies throughout the
entire device was equal.
So if you had a
limited mobility,
if you had a certain
higher density of carriers
in the front than
toward the back,
you'd have a difference
in the chemical potential
through the thickness
of your device.
They assumed infinite mobility.
So it was a very simple,
yet elegantly insightful
model that, upon first
submission, was rejected.
So the first time they submitted
this model for publication
it was rejected outright.
And it took them another several
months of edits, probably
about a year, and
they resubmitted it.
And then it became
a sleeper paper.
It wasn't cited that much.
If you go to the Web of
Science, for example,
and look at this
manuscript, you'll
see that the number of
citations in the early years
was rather limited.
Nowadays there
isn't a talk about
the fundamental efficiency of
a solar cell without mentioning
the Shockley-Queisser
efficiency limit.
That's coming directly
from this paper right here.
And that serves as a
motivational story for you.
If your paper is rejected,
just remember that now you're
along with some several
esteemed individuals who
have set precedence in
the field of photovoltaics
and are Nobel worthy.
So that's my personal opinion.
If you fall into that category,
don't feel discouraged.
Regroup and find a way to
make your paper better.
You have a copy
of this manuscript
right here, by the way, in
your handouts for today.
And interestingly, through
their detailed balance model,
they obtained an ultimate
efficiency versus wavelength,
or energy in this
case, curve that looks
very similar to the curve that
you derived in your earlier
homeworks, where you just
assumed two loss mechanisms.
One was non-absorption
of light and the other
was thermalization of carriers.
So the detailed
balance model, the way
they reached this point,
is different, fundamentally
different.
The physics that was
assumed is basically
listed out right here.
But the end result is fairly
similar to the rough back
of the envelope calculation
that you performed
in an earlier homework.
So again, just to
go up, they assumed
that the photons with energies
greater than the band gap
are absorbed, create
one electron hole pair.
They assume thermalization.
So these were your
two assumptions
that you did in the homework.
Then they do a few
additional things.
They assume that
radiative losses
occur within the material,
that not every carrier is
collected-- that's
important-- so you have
radiative losses in
your device, so that
reduces the performance.
And then they assume
further that there
is a thermodynamic loss in
their device, in other words,
that you don't extract the
full band gap of energy,
but that there's a
thermodynamic loss
as you go from band to band,
which would be the band gap
energy, to the difference or
separation of the quasi Fermi
energies, which is
this delta mu here,
which is the change in
the chemical potential
from the front side to the
back side of the device.
So there are some additional
loss terms that were included.
For a full description of
the detailed balance limit,
and all the math, I
definitely encourage
you go to this website.
As well, Peter Wurfel's
text does a wonderful job
of describing this.
And of course, you
have your paper here.
You can read through the
original paper yourself,
or perhaps suggest it
at an upcoming journal
meeting for your group.
Here is the calculation of the
detailed balance limit for AM0
and AM1.5, essentially as
a function of band gap,
coming from the PVCDROM.
And you can see how silicon
and gallium arsenide are pretty
close to the theoretical
maximum in terms
of the theoretical maximum
efficiency for a single band
gap semiconductor material.
So this curve right here,
again, is just representing one
band gap material, a
single band gap material.
So let's take it from
here and venture forward
into some more realistic
performance reduction effects.
We can, for instance, take
into account recombination
mechanisms that aren't
only-- for example,
that aren't only radiative.
We can take Auger recombination.
We can take Shockley-Read-Hall
recombination into account.
We can also take what's called
photon recycling into account.
So what is photon recycling?
Photon recycling is when you
have a radiative recombination
event, and that photon gets
trapped within the material.
It's not allowed to escape.
But it gets trapped because,
for example, off the top,
there's an index of
refraction mismatch.
Or the angle at which it
tries to exit is too oblique,
and so you have total internal
reflection within your device.
And you eventually
have reabsorption.
So that's called
photon recycling
because you have a radiative
recombination event.
It emits a photon inside
of your solar cell device,
and that photon bounces
around a few more times
until it's
reabsorbed, generating
another electron hole pair.
And that is, essentially,
the major boost in some
of these ultra thin, high
performance solar cell
materials such as the Alta
Devices record efficiency 28%
gallium arsenide
cell has the ability
to do this photon recycling.
Now how do you modify the
detailed balance limit
to account for finite mobility?
I suspect this
corner of the room
is going to want to hear this.
There is a beautiful piece
of work done by [INAUDIBLE].
The PhD thesis is
even more insightful
than the manuscript in terms
of actually breaking down
each individual component.
A great deal of modeling went
into this, including photon
recycling, including
some things that
are very difficult to model.
And the effect of
finite mobility
was calculated on a modified
detailed balance limit model.
And you can see
number one, that curve
that's starting here at the 20.
That is for a mobility that
is close to the optimal.
If you drop by an
order of magnitude,
or two orders of
magnitude, relative
to the maximum mobility
inside of a material,
your performance begins
to degrade considerably.
And now you can
understand why silicon,
or crystalline
silicon, which has,
say, hole mobilities
somewhere in the range
of a few hundreds of centimeters
squared per volt second.
So keep that number
in your mind,
on the order of
hundreds of centimeters
squared per volt hole mobility.
Now you compare to
amorphous silicon,
which has something in the
range of 10 to the minus 3
to 10 to the minus 1
centimeters per volt second.
And you begin to see why those
materials with poor mobilities
are really impacted in
terms of their performance.
There is a method to calculate
the impact of limited mobility
on device performance.
And if that intrigues
you, I would definitely
refer you to this manuscript.
One very simple way
to think about it
is, at least for
a band conductor,
you would have a certain
diffusion length.
At least a first order
would be the diffusivity
times the lifetime
and the diffusivity
would be related to the mobility
inside of your material.
So your mobility is factoring
into your diffusion length,
and the diffusion length
is affecting how many
charge carriers are collected.
So that's a simple way to
think about the problem.
A similar related approach that
kind of pulls all this together
in a graphical form is
at the very last page--
some of the very last pages
of Peter Wurfel's text.
And this is going through
the efficiency calculation
that we just saw, starting
from a certain amount of light
that's not absorbed.
The light that is absorbed--
so that's efficiency loss
mechanism number one--
for a thin device,
let's say light
trapping isn't perfect.
We're at around 74%
efficiency of light trapping,
of absorption of light.
Let's say now that we have
a thermalization event that
results in about a 33%
loss, so we're down to 67%
efficiency for the
thermalization of charge
carriers, just a step.
So now our combined
efficiency is
going to be the multiplicative
product of those two.
So just the thermalization
of charge carriers
results in a 33% drop
of an efficiency.
Now there's a delta between,
say, the band to band
and the actual chemical
potential inside
of our material once we consider
the ensemble of carriers, not
just those free carriers,
but the ensemble of carriers,
which is going to dictate
the ultimate potential.
So we have some carriers that
are excited and others that
aren't.
These thermodynamic losses
results in another 36% drop.
And finally, fill
factor losses, which
represent the solar cell
and practical operation.
When we have series resistance
and so forth, another 11%.
So if we multiply these
four numbers together,
we drop down to 28.
And the beauty of doing
breaking things out like this--
and what Peter Wurfel
does very nicely
is dives into each of
these in great detail
and explains to you exactly
how those numbers are derived.
The beauty of doing
something like this is you
can pick the lowest
number, say, 64 and 67,
and say, I want
to work on those.
I want to make my PhD thesis
about those parameters
because that has
the biggest impact.
And that's what you can do
with an analysis like this.
Now you can take this further.
You can say, well,
these are only four
of the many parameters
that impact performance.
I would like to look
at many, many more.
And that's what one has done
for crystalline silicon, which
is arguably the most researched
and, from the point of view
of physical understanding,
advanced solar cell technology.
We can see a variety of
performance loss mechanisms
that have been taken into
account inside of the crystal
silicon devices.
This was an invited
talk by Dick Swanson,
the founder of Sun Power,
former professor at Stanford,
who pulled this together,
a very nice presentation.
He speaks with authority because
Sun Power produces the highest
efficiency crystalline silicon
solar cell device commercially.
And interestingly,
right here, this
is the thermodynamic limit and
the calculated limit efficiency
versus time.
So we start from Prince.
That was the very first one.
And we have Shockley-Queisser
up there, and so forth.
So the theoretical limit
of solar cell performance
has also changed with time.
And their calculations vary.
So it's important to be
able to understand this
as well as you go into it.
And here is the actual best
laboratory performance.
So if we had, for example, a
25% efficient cell over there,
it would already be higher than
some of the earlier efficiency
calculations for
crystalline silicon.
What Dick Swanson thinks is the
practical limit is right there.
That's the Swanson
prediction, that we
won't get much above 26%
for crystalline silicon.
So loss mechanisms
visualized right here,
and several good readings
on efficiency limits.
What I'm going to
do is pause here.
There is still some
material in your text,
and some really cool
demos that we're
going to have to wait
until next week to see.